alaska is the largest u.s state
it is also the least densely populated
among its great treasures the untouched
wilderness
but much of that is now being destroyed
wildfires are not a new phenomenon here
but they are changing they are becoming
more frequent and more intense
so much so that this year local
firefighters here in anderson were
unable to get them under control
when a fire happens and they get
bigger than the local unit can handle
like so here in anderson they have some
local volunteer firefighters
but but they're very small
so when the fire gets bigger than what
they can control they will call for
outside help and help has come from all
over the u.s kate earhart from montana
has been battling places countrywide for
more than 20 years this is her fifth
time in alaska she is now supervising a
team of 500 firefighters deployed to
help control one wildfire sadly this
property couldn't be saved
it's really when fires like this one
start in and around populated areas even
a lightly populated area like this that
it becomes a problem
year after year you hear that i've never
seen fire behavior like this before and
so i would say
this abnormal weather is the new normal
it's getting harder to fight fires
resources are getting scarcer and we're
dealing with
winds like this this summer more than
264 individual fires have destroyed 1.25
million hectares of land across the
state the blaze in anderson is now under
control but the damage is extensive and
the strong winds pose a risk too
this used to be a forest we can still
see smoke up there the firefighters are
still trying to get that fire under
control and we can strongly smell it
local people have had to evacuate their
homes among them don and dorothy wins
are accelerating the blaze
they took all the firefighters out
because it was moving so fast
it was like three or four miles west of
us
and they had a fire line
you know that they built with dozers
and it was a windy day not windy as
today
and it jumped the line and then it moved
like three or four miles
in just five hours
when they returned the fire was under
control
it was like
kind of like surreal there was smoke and
fires were still burning in the trees
out here
and the firemen were with us and i think
they were with us because
they
maybe you know it would be traumatic to
go and see but we they said right away
your house is safe
this time they were lucky but there will
certainly be wildfires here again and
experts say global warming may make them
more severe lightning is a principal
cause of the big wildfires in alaska
and so just a little bit of warming just
a little bit of added moisture more
lightning strikes on ground that is
drier than it used to be because the
snow is melting earlier
giving it more chances to dry out so
you've got a flammable landscape we have
this confluence
of events
that are being driven by the large-scale
warming we're getting more and more
fires that are just incinerators they
turn the whole landscape look like moon
in the middle of the ashes hope remains
that at least a part of this charred
land might return to life
until the next wildfires hit again